host hoes or prudes
hose my friend well actually yeah I've
got friends though and they're married
and actually second and then second
question and do their men have any idea
so no okay no no what about no I
honestly do think you find like most of
these like single 40 year old women that
like are like sad that they're not wiped
up and they're sad that they don't have
kids in that it's because they were hoes
like in their past and they regret it so
much and like that goes back to the
Brittany Renner thing I was saying like
it's really dangerous for young women
because they do end up regretting it you
think prudes get whiffed up yeah you say
fruits um you said hoes you think hoes
get wafed up fast confidence okay what
about you you think hoes get wafed up
faster me yeah
um I think just something I don't well
out of my friends the ones that were
hoes when we were younger are married
the ones that weren't are married
because they've been very career driven
okay what do you think I think it's a
mixture I feel like I know certain
friends who are hoes hoes but their man
don't know so that's why they get
whiffed up but then I know certainly
improves who get no men at all so I feel
like it just depends how you present
yourself do the prudes present
themselves like hoes
um no but then I feel like
it just depends because I know majority
of my friends are approved I also feel
like they don't
like put themselves in a position to
date like for example let's say they
like to dress up wear makeup and just
look cute I feel like they actively just
withdraw from the game and they don't
put themselves out there like they just
don't have game like that's the best way
to explain it where the hoes like have a
it goes both ways but like that yeah it
goes a bit more game they know how to
make money yeah and I think because
they've been with more men they know the
right things to say they understand that
a little bit better than the people yeah
but then I know certain friends that are
just so herish that because everybody
knows they don't get wife so it just
like it just literally depends on how
you present yourself really
I'm just curious what roughly the girls
I don't even know if you could do this
because I mean they might lie to YouTube
but like if you're Degas roughly what
body count gets waved to the quickest
[Music]
you guys may know roughly because you
know the behind the scenes so I'm just
curious if you no I think what um sorry
what was your name Bella no um Valentina
Valentina
um what you said was a very valid point
because the girls that may have slept
through a few bodies they will know how
to act to pretend that they're this you
know High Almighty and but there's
someone that's actually a prude
they'll just keep themselves to
themselves and not go out there whereas
someone that slept with 10 bodies 10 15
20 whatever they'll go up and and
they'll play the game oh I I I have a
number and I can validate okay okay go
ahead what do you think I think it's
something I'll ask you after sorry go
ahead I think it's seven plus seven but
seven to ten seven to about 10 12. the
reason is the fastest yeah I think so
but because and I can kind of tell I I
judge everyone just by like how they are
and I don't do any of this like oh this
was your past I can see I can see your
passing your eye isn't it so yeah just
just look just talk to people you can
see I'm sorry I don't believe men though
well there are a lot of losers out here
but I definitely know that you're not
getting anything [ __ ] anyway we don't
know [ __ ] so seven seven plus because
she's probably he's a woman who probably
had two or three serious boyfriends in
high school and then they've probably
had about two to three kind of sexual
kind of Encounters in University and
then they figure out so the whole thing
is about being smart enough some girls
sleep on a little bit and then they
figure it out some people keep on
sleeping but that seven Mark is when
like she's seen enough she kind of gets
it now you've been to UNI you've had the
high school boyfriends you've had a
couple dudes that you need you you get
how this works you're gonna find a good
guy when it gets past like 12 clearly
you haven't figured this out so clearly
you know it just extends and I can see
it like I disagree because one of my
friends yeah she's my age she's 20.
she's married and I'm not joking her
body count is 65.
that's not a whole liar come on no it's
not a normal person that's what I'm
saying like some people are like I feel
like women have the power of like again
like I feel like men because I don't
want to be rude but I feel like men have
fragile Egos and once a woman knows how
to work around it
like like I said how you present
yourself is crazy like men didn't make
up that say what he doesn't know doesn't
hurt him we didn't make that up
we didn't make that up what he doesn't
know doesn't hurt him we did not make
that but you know why that was made up
everyone men say that I mean I
don't know what a phrase came from
not wait yeah wait um so I don't
actually know where the phrase came from
I always hear men say that with like
cheating which he doesn't know I always
had a woman say it um
it's in a situation where we know women
are adding numbers on that they just are
racing you know I mean erasing it
doesn't exist so yeah but at some point
knowing knowing is just like negative
benefit like it's not needed you're not
helping yourself
a tree in the woods if you if you're not
there to hear it fold did you actually
did it actually fall I'm curious do you
think if he found out the husband would
um would they get divorced
no
um because of their religion as well oh
she's religious yeah Muslim as well
[Music]
I feel like probably you know I don't
know I really don't know but I feel like
they would not be should get stoned I
think there'd be a lot of family
it's not nice to say well I've also got
another question though what if yeah
this person has a body count of two and
they're with their mouth for a year and
then she [ __ ] his brother does that
make her a hoe or does that make her
yeah
but she has a body count of two yeah
like I don't I don't think it's like
black and white like I think there's
some things that you can do that are
just like mad I like the way
her body counts together
okay guys no side stop um if her body
counts too but she slept with two guys
in one night
is that better than a girl with seven
no that's what I'm saying
is a hoe really based on body the
spectrum of hoism is so vast yeah we're
gonna be here all night
numbers it's based on intention exactly
and now what hotel why does it not
because it's not listening
thank you I usually talk over people and
I've been quiet
anyway I agree with my name what with
what my Nemesis said I actually like it
today I'm proud of you because you
cannot call a woman a hoe when actually
she's experiment so she can know and
make better decisions because it's very
dangerous I'm listen I'm not even
talking to YouTube because I think
that's an exception to the rule in the
day in today's age but I think it's very
irresponsible for you to expect a woman
to go into a relationship with you and
think and know what it is that you bring
to the table as a man where she doesn't
know what a man can bring to the table
he can't bring to the table women need
to go through heartbreak women need to
experience men to know and be better
trust me trust me listen listen do you
know what especially in today's age it
is necessary because we we are actually
programmed to make bad decisions because
the world around us is actually not that
great I think so we need to learn
about what why why do you need more
trauma to bring into a relationship it's
not about trauma it's about experience
come on
capping every time you break up with
someone or you get broken up
with it it's baggage maybe it's lessons
maybe even a kid and you can you could
you could phrase it like that but most
men would disagree because we all
complain to the next guy but you know
let me tell you something about men and
this is the thing I think is becoming
the problem
men were used to women succumbing to
their needs and their wants because they
needed a man to survive no no no I'm not
I'm just telling you wait a second right
which means that now that a woman can
work anyone can provide for herself many
to kind of relax on their standards
because you will not get a woman that is
going to be a virgin in this day and age
and be a woman that is actually
naturally and I mean socially accepted
to go to the East and I'll just fly to
the East and find out yeah and how are
you going to feel good today there's one
on the panel but she was 15 when she met
her and she yeah
you know but most men don't expect okay
okay how many men here expect to get a
virgin
okay okay
so so most men don't expect a virgin
they just don't want a girl that's had
her ass on her Instagram that has only
fans and that slept with more than like
15 dudes guys I've you know I've
interviewed a lot of guys it seems to be
ten but then I asked them a second
question and then it's like yeah we have
chemistry Maybe
I do think so like a lot of guys
initially chat to me because they expect
me to be like some crazy [ __ ] Hunter
who's just gonna like jump on their dick
first chance I get but yeah like so
they'll only like me in a sexual sense
but then once I do tell them I'm a
virgin and like if they believe me
um because of how I present myself
um they do start to think of me
different and they do start to look at
me in a way where it's like yeah I could
wife her like yeah like I could look
past the ass on Instagram like yeah
because they do value like
territory would you delete all those
pictures or would you leave them up no
no I'd have to have someone that was
like because I like expressing myself in
that way I like showing off my body I
like that but
yeah but she's still a virgin she's pure
so isn't that good no no curiosity I
just wanted to know if she's really not
for respect you know I mean I think most
men would like prefer neither like I
don't think they'd care that much I'm
not saying like like but she gets that
she's not I mean as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible